ok vado starnutire tutti ragazzi e poi
minuti questo video sono fuori gente ci
siamo subito nyon in genere cipolle
fanno piangere a me fan starnutire non
si sa perché è una roba è una roba
l'altro credo che sia la musica del menù
più bella che io abbia mai sentito nella
mia vita
sembra veramente un qualcuno che stia
cercando di sforzarsi per cagare però
che a scelta lei a fantastico questo
giocare dico pagana la banana
aspetterò qui dovrebbe essere un lavoro
molto semplice entra prendi soldi ed
esci e quindi è un colpo nel senso della
cipolla è un ladro mentre la banana è
l'autista genia la cipolla e bella entra
dentro prendi i soldi e le ci fu ripreso
ce la faccio vai così ti vedo carica è
sono io a posso già muovermi intenti te
e allora io mi muovo così perché bella
lei la pistola più realistica che abbia
mai visto
va bene e siccome io sono una cipolla
vediamo di finire in fretta perché è un
lavoro che solo una cipolla può fare è
un market
quindi devo entrare e rubare delle cose
tipo ma c'è il cassiere cassiere so da
sola
lush drink caffi clerc la melanzana e si
subito da questo sto è la madonna c'è
anche lui fucile
anzi a misteriosi ho preso i soldi
ciao veloce la cena c'è la feroce veloce
veloce veloce veloce lui da pannella
veloce e scappa cosa brava grandissimo
ultimo lavoro suo uomo più una cipolla
che uomo è stato fantastico è bello
perché io sono capace
ho sentito colpi di spari asi si imita
sono degli spari ma come fai una banana
abbiamo lanciato 300 cento a 4 dollari
pensavo che se fossimo stati fortunati
ne avremmo guadagnato i 150 e invece è
andata meglio siamo ricchi orca [ __ ] ce
la faremo ragazzi dobbiamo andare avanti
perché noi possiamo farcela
banana falomi ma che cazzo succede io
non pensavo nella mia vita di seguire
una banana ai la roba qua l'europa
gokhan è un cocco ai soldi stanno
spacciando una banana e un cocco
e la prima volta che faccio un business
con te vero burro ma stanno spacciando
del burro guarda yemen per cassa justin
bieber è tra l'altro ragazzi che cocco
figo cioè come un gioco
hai ucciso il cocco hai ucciso un povero
cocco innocente spacciava e basta banana
cosa hai fatto tutto questo poteva
essere evitato
no è finito no fermi cosa sta succedendo
calmi
miike lasciato il gioco hanno anche un
hanno continuato nel senso che adesso
c'è anche il cocco perché giusto banana
ancora aridaje ho già rapinato gusto
cosa devo fare ancora spiegatemi cosa
vuoi da me adesso sì adesso alza le
braccia poi in alto melanzana della
minkia i soldi della cassa e tutto
quello che c'è negli armadietti solito
non ti faccio piangere giorno per favore
non farvi al male perché le dame i soldi
adesso lo sai che cos'è questo zio è una
pistola fa ma questa guarda come sa fare
bene michael jackson era oddio abbassa
le tue armi adesso nostro hanno mostrato
in faccia a scusarsi che mi ero di merda
io ti aspetta aspetta i miei amici in un
attimo
mi hanno fatto che sono riusciti a
uccidere una cipolla ragazzino e allo
zio si chiami laila bastard devo tornare
indietro prima che arrivi la pula sono
solo una cipolla via veloce ho fatto
allora falomi ce la faccia stavolta
siamo più cazzuti di prima quindi
evitiamo di andare ai la roba sì sì sì
basta
prendi il burro e usciamo di qua come
usciamo cia veloce esco mi spiace zio
giuro mi spiace perché è un bravo
ragazzo si vedeva
ma noi ce ne fottiamo andiamo ecco lo
abbiamo pure investito come se non
bastasse tele meritato era un
principiante e chiudendo e tutto quel
burro a un nuovo acquirente non lo so
però non deve anche poi anche evitare
gli spara gen
andiamocene scappiamo l'aj scappa prendi
la dinamite sul mio banco e va bene ciao
ragazzi quebec e belga rives shafiq c'è
un jackson credo sia un jack ciao
ragazzi è solo una cipolla con le armi
ma giuro che non la uso che bel
soprammobile a questa la dinamite posso
prenderla si perfetto di sel e melanzana
per questo abbiamo fatto a rapimento
alla melanzana ce l'abbiamo la prossima
missione età come ha preso la roba
perfetto di mandare dai tacco e allora
vai così minchia che siamo forti
the best car hai mai visto una ferrari
fratello voglio sapere va bene ho preso
la roba sono pronto per andare andiamo
perché retromarcia che bel sogno di
retromarcia che sembra poco reale
anche se fatta con l'esofago tipo
normale che stia facendo retromarcia in
casa non lo so che banana che cazzo stai
facendo perché c'è una pallina da tennis
è una poche volte è la più bella epoque
e vuoi che io abbia mai vista per carità
perfetto questa dovrebbe essere la
location a ok premi f per sparare un
proiettile in aria ea spaventare le
persone va bene la dinamite che hai
preso dalla casa premi w per lanciarla
ne abbiamo soltanto una quindi fate
insieme va bene siamo ragazzi ce la
possiamo fare siamo pronti per questa
rabbia devo fare tutto io lavoro sporco
un ciao sono perché c'è un brocco labbra
colori non far caso la mia pistola finta
ciao ragazzi perché belli che seguendo
ecco qua senti buon uomo e un dollaro
per un tacco sono sei un ladro ma tu
stai friggendo bravo e sentite a questa
è la cassaforte con prossimo inclusa
mentiva e nel mentre ios cassino a casa
ce l'ho fatta tecmo rave ai premi per i
soldi prendi soldi
ciao zio è appreso che ovviamente dentro
tutti i fast food
c'è la cassaforte quei soldi ma vi siete
spaventati non amano devo ancora sparare
in aria
ecco adesso potete essere spaventati
city sparassi in faccia ucciso in corsa
cazzaro un hamburger ho sempre sognato
di uccidere un nachos in vita mia casa
io mi sveglio la mattina e dico quando è
che uccide un naso stesso papa fa ho
fatto una cosa orribile scherzavo
andarono a scappare da scappare e morto
ormai mi sentivo e non ho nulla contro
le idee per carità profilo uccidere
anche tu che fai le patate ecco gli
facevano schifo in rotta sono un killer
è anche il tacco enormi renold roccolo
ecco adesso adesso adesso c'è un po lo è
dopo tutto sto casino ma godiamoci un
bel ballo alla michael jackson
[Musica]
ciao patatina e banana sparati st vuol
che piacere che io rapino di tacco al
ritmo di moonwalk fantastic voyage en
mer che sarà è la fine del feedback fi
libero fino a fini c'è finito è finito
così nel senso io ho giocato una roba
che è finita così va bene tanto in fondo
io sono sono giapponese credo di avere
appena giocato al gioco al videogame che
vi cambierà l'esistenza questo è il
video il gioco della vita ragazzi
scaricatelo tutti perché per l'amor di
dio non c'e gta che tenga qualcosa da
ragazzi come quello che l'episodio è
stato c'è io non ho parole nel senso che
questo è il videogioco
proprio il video gioco in sé è
complimenti per averlo creato perché
grazia di dio
lasciate un mi piace sa anche voi
pensate lo stesso ma ne sono convinto
non c'è bisogno però che avviene sempre
100 ragazzi che ora sente subito
piaciuto al momento è un mi piace a
capace di ben due contendenti
se avessi discrete decimi lavoro così
bello ragazzo